we have a voicemail number it's to 192
david p this has been a really weird
week for voicemail and this is
absolutely no exception to that does
anybody understand what this call is
about take a listen yeah sure
yeah sports politics in the disc
enjoined they are one was the
judeo-christian theology it in the very
last of this red carpet walk but they're
doctors and scientists leading the way
party one question i've got left
not many but this is one big one now
okay
despite elegy run Hollywood anyways
thank you take care bye I don't know I
don't I mean the question at the end was
the Scientology run Hollywood but it
started with judeo-christian values and
a whole bunch of other stuff I don't
know if I'm having an issue this week
where my abilities to understand have
been hindered in some way but I have
understood almost nothing in terms of
voicemails and hey tree at mail this
week you know those long winded
questions that start out with this
entire narrative to explain the question
yes coming up of course I know that he
was trying to do if you if you've ever
listened to the live phone call segment
on the show you become very familiar
with very long-winded statements that
are not really questions did you
understand any of that Rachel I didn't I
think he was trying to make sense of who
runs Hollywood but I'm not sure but
let's go around Pat does Scientology run
Hollywood or is it the Jews which is
another popular conspiracy yes do you
think so yes about yeah okay Pat's YES
on both conspiracy theories the
Scientology run Hollywood yes you you
also say that no not actually oh I
really have no idea maybe they do I
really don't I just read that
Scientology has its own prison maybe
that was fake news and I fell for it I
don't know how but Italy it sounds very
real I'm not going to lie based on the
documentaries I've seen and people being
held against their will on the bonus
show today climate scientists launching
an anonymous hotline for government
workers to report Donald Trump meddling
with their business Walmart will no
longer sell the bulletproof black lives
matter shirt but they will sell the
regular
black lives matter shirt and should you
be able to legally call non-dairy milk
milk is almond milk actually milk if it
doesn't have any milk in it hmm vegan
producer Pat anxious to weigh in on this
particular issue as you can imagine all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show david pakman.com slash membership
to sign up for membership and of course
I'm wearing the custom and exclusive
hatred mail t-shirt which is available
only as a donation through our indiegogo
fundraiser at david pakman.com slash
donate this is a great shirt I'm wearing
it in the cantaloupe color
it's available in pistachio in moss in
charcoal and all sorts of eccentrically
named colors and you get to pick the
size you want david pakman.com slash
donate check it out we'll talk to you on
the bonus show